I'm Barbra Meade I'm one of the owners
here at politics and prose and I have a
real pleasure tonight to introduce
Steven Levitt who had who is the
co-author of hit this new book
Freakonomics a rogue economist explores
the hidden side of everything I was a
little I read the book I enjoyed it a
great deal but even at the end I was
mystified about what a rogue economist
was so I just I just been sitting back
in the office asking Steven Levitt what
is the road rogue economist I mean I
want to make sure that it was not
somebody who was dangerous but it but it
turns out that a rogue economist is
somebody that is not the first
definition of rogue which is a scoundrel
it is somebody who is the second
definition of rope which is fun-loving
mischievous and that certainly is a good
description of this book the book of the
book is a pure delight and for
Washington audiences I thought it has
some very special appeal and two of the
areas where that he kind of turns
conventional wisdom on its head for it
for things that concern us one the
conventional wisdom says that there must
be some correlation between the crime
rate and the size of a police force in
other words if you don't have that many
police around you're going to have a
high crime rate if you have a lot of
police around you're gonna have a low
crime rate well as it turns out
Washington DC has three times the size
of the police force of Denver Colorado
we have eight times the number of
murders of Denver of Denver Colorado and
Steven Levitt I'm sure we'll explain of
how this conventional wisdom gets turned
on its head there and then of course at
what's always important to us here in
Washington is campaign finance
the conventional wisdom is the candidate
who collects the most money will be the
winner it's true but it's not that money
produces winning candidates it's at
winning candidates produce money and he
will explain that also I want you all to
be sure to know that he that Steven
Levitt has been awarded the James Bates
Bates Clark award which is for the medal
which is given every two years to the
best economist under 40 so it's our
special privilege to have in this room
tonight and you will be able to see when
he talks of why that he has gotten this
award so here is Steven mother
thank you all for coming one thing I can
say for sure as an economist is that
whoever set the prices for seat set the
price way too low tonight we'd all be
better off if there have been a cover
chart up front but anyway thank you all
for coming I have a confession to make
which is that I have never done a book
reading before in fact I've only been to
one in my entire life and it was David
Sedaris and so I don't think it was very
good model for what I'm planning on
doing today so I'm just gonna wing it
and I try not to talk for too long and
then leave plenty of time for for people
to to ask questions so in particular
actually I wasn't going to talk about
either of the issues you were gonna
bring Hubble either crime or campaigns
money although I'm happy to take
questions on those I was going to tell
just a story of a few stories and it's
really the story of Sudhir Venkatesh and
how I met Sudhir Venkatesh and and the
research that that came out of that that
meeting because I think it captures in
many ways the flavor of this book better
than any other story in the book at
least it's my favorite story that's in
the book and it's this book is about
many different things it's about you
know the part I'm going to talk about
now which is why drug dealers live with
their mothers if they're if they're you
know living so large and it's about
campaign spending it's about why crime
went down in the 1990s it's about
whether the first name that you give to
your child has any impact on their life
outcomes and it's about parenting so
it's hard to convey in a short period of
time the feeling of the book but the
book is really ultimately it's about
data and about my attempts I supposed to
be a data detective and to search for
truth and data but to tell stories that
make it more interesting than the usual
searches for truth in data so let me let
me go back to when I first met Sood even
before I met Sudhir so I was lucky
enough to be at the society fellows at
Harvard which is this amazing elite
academic institution that I that I
lucked into
by virtue of having the best the
wittiest conversational net of my life
when I needed to have it and that gave
me three years to do whatever I wanted
with no obligations and so and with
these great scholars like Amartya Sen
and Nobel Prize winning physicist and so
I heard that in the next group that was
coming with a guy named Sudhir Venkatesh
and everybody raved about co2 Venkatesh
he was a he was an ethnographer someone
who who did went out in the field and
and and lived with people study their
behavior and wrote about it so I figured
well I'll look up this guy and see what
he's all about so the only thing he had
published at that time I found was an
article in a post modern sociology
journal and the title was rappin wit a
gangsta okay that was the name of the
article that wasn't exactly my thing and
I was my taste for a little more narrow
back then but I said I'll go get it out
of library anyway so I got it and I was
surprised because it was really just a
conversation
it was Sudhir talking with a gang leader
and and again I was thinking is this you
know how is this scholarship what it
says but the thing was is the more I
read it the more I read this is really
it was interesting and I learned a lot
and yeah I remember a few things from
what that was vintage so this was a
college-educated gang leader who had
worked in the management information
systems the computer found a data part
of a downtown business in Chicago before
he said wait a second this is a waste of
my time I can make more money running
the gang I'm gonna drop out of that and
go to the gang so what was interesting
is that here was this this gang leader
who had lived on both sides really of
the of you know culture the law and the
thing I remember that was maybe most
interesting was that he said you know
the police are very unfair and you know
it turns out in fact the police aren't I
think very unfair and uneven but what he
said that was interesting was he said
you know the gangs are out killing
people I don't deny that that we're all
killing people and we get some heat for
that but what really bothers me is that
the guys who are running Anheuser
and Miller we know they're killing the
you know they're killing each other too
but why doesn't the media cover that and
Ford and General Motors we know that
they're killing all the executives from
the other companies but why doesn't the
media cover it and it was just very
striking because amidst all of this
discussion which made total sense and
showed a real understanding of the world
by this gang leader there was this other
piece which is least as far as I know is
completely counterfactual and it was and
it really opened my eyes to thinking
about what you could learn from this
approach so then I met sit here and at
the time I was I was doing some really
uninteresting work trying to model in
theory what gangs were doing until I met
Sudhir we began talking and immediately
liked him
and so in that first conversation I said
well it's too bad you don't have any
data you know if you just had some data
this would be so much fun to analyze and
he said well what do you mean by data
and I said you know like you know
there's the financial books like the the
quantities of craft distilling and the
prices and the wages I named up all
these things he kept on nodding his head
and you see I have all those but I don't
know I never know what to do with them
because they're just numbers and I don't
know anything about numbers and so I
said well can I get them and he said
sure and so that began the most unequal
partnership co-authoring partnership in
the history of mankind as Sudhir spent
seven years living with the gang going
to jail being shot the car windows being
shot of his car and I would sit back in
my office waiting for the next day to
dump to come in so I could put in my
Excel spreadsheet and you know spend 15
minutes and I liked the data before I
sent him out in the field to get some
more data so let me tell you this story
about about how Sudhir got in with the
gang because it's my it's my favorite
story although the problem with the
story is that every punchline in this
story ends with a profanity
so I actually can't really tell the
stories very effectively in this context
but in the book you get the you get the
unn the unabridged version so so Sudhir
had been a suburban college kid and he's
he's he's South Asian very dark
and he did he come to the Arista Chicago
to study sociology as we say in the book
and he had spent the previous four
months following the Grateful Dead okay
and so he looked the part so he had hair
you know here all the way down his back
and he's you know a big guy but you know
he was dark-skinned but not black and he
had long hair so it was kind of bending
you know gender lines as well and so he
came to Willie William Julius Wilson
who's one of the great sociologists of
our time and he was doing a book about
when jobs disappear in Chicago here
sending out graduate students to do
surveys all around the city of Chicago
so he took one look at Sudhir and he
said this is the guy I've needed to send
to the housing project because he didn't
have a lot of graduate students he felt
comforting to the housing project so
Sudhir marches down to the housing
project with a clipboard in hand and set
of questions and somebody comes up to
the buildings and these were buildings
that were virtually abandoned and you
know they've done this very complicated
randomization based on the last census
of which doors you're supposed to knock
on and not know there's nobody there but
he's walking around but he's you know
trying hard it's getting dark and so we
hear some voices up in the stairwell so
he figures he'll go up the stairwell so
it goes around the stairwell and he
comes up on some some young males you
know halfway between kids and men and
they're shooting guys and so they're
alarmed they're not used to people
coming around the court especially not
people that look like yeah I'm career on
the corner and they leap up and turns
out one kids got a gun he considered
actually doesn't know what it is for a
while he's not used to having guns it's
like the kids wagging a gun in his face
but it's dark so I can't really tell it
is and so you know they're like what are
you doing here and he says well I'm from
the University of Chicago and I wanted
to give you a survey and so so that's
not even the funny parts and the funny
part is the first question
so say okay give us the first question
okay and I swear to god he says this is
true although it's it's I don't believe
it
the first question is how does it feel
to be poor in black in America and then
the choices are very good good
bad and very bad those are the four
choices of the heavens so he quickly
learns it turns on this that the the
true answer he gets whenever he asks
that question is and it involves a lot
of profanity I'm not allowed to actually
yeah I probably can't say that answer in
this group so that didn't really improve
his his status with these folks when he
asked those questions it's how they
didn't know what to do with them they
ended up holding him hostage overnight
and and so they're drinking beers and
and he's drinking beers and you know
he's asking him so there's a lot of
gunshots going off in the distance and
he's he's asking them all sorts of
questions about their lives and how they
feel about death and whatnot and they
still don't have no idea what to make
out of it and so you know since they're
drinking beer they go they go to the
bathroom up and this and this stairwell
one floor above so we just go in there
too so he does that you know makes it
through the night and in the morning
they finally decide that they can let
him go I mean I say have no idea what
he's doing this till they've figured out
and so what he does more or less as it
goes home takes a shower and then goes
back to spend the night with him again
the next night okay so when he shows up
you know they're like what do you what
are you doing back here he says well I
enjoyed hanging out with you so much
last night I thought maybe we could do
it again and so that in the end is how
he starts to get in with the gang and
then literally what he does for the next
seven years it's been all of his days
and many of his nights in the housing
project with the gang literally going to
jail with them and you know literally
getting his car window shot out getting
the police to plant
crack cocaine in his vehicle and arrest
him for because the police didn't like
the fact that he was hanging out
documenting what was going on in these
neighborhoods in which the police were
choosing not to do anything about the
drug trade and and so what came out of
the research I think what's what's
what's great about it this is data no
one's ever had so first of all no one
has really ever been in the gang the way
severe was in the gang so it was you
know they all knew so I should make
they're all the gang members knew what
he was up to and in fact he was started
out he'd give them what he wrote before
published anything and no one and they
could not figure out what he was doing
because like he couldn't know why anyone
want to read the stuff that he would
write and and they felt sorry for him it
turned out because for a number of
reasons number one he he didn't have a
job right so he was just hanging out
with them all day and I thought this guy
can't be doing very well
and number two we had very dark skin and
so they figured that he couldn't
possibly have much of a chance in
American society number three it turns
out he didn't drive he drove a really
crappy car and so they felt sweat from
that but but the big one he told me the
big thing that he said he only had one
girlfriend and so he couldn't be very
high-status if he only could could have
one girlfriend at a time and so all of
those combined they felt sorry for him
and that's actually why they were so
helpful in giving him the data and
cooperating and answering her question
so the combination of him having this
incredible knowledge and understanding
of the game and also being just
incredibly smart I mean it's like I
can't stress enough how how difficult I
think it is having read other
ethnography not to become completely a
booster for whatever group you study is
very hard for people who get so involved
in the culture to not just become
defenders of that culture but he was
smart enough to really keep an open eye
and then to have this data combined with
his insights was really something that
we never had and they were doing
prosecutions of the big gangs in Chicago
around the same time and what's
interesting is I talked to the lead
prosecutor and they had nothing like we
had their data was pathetic compared to
the data that we had and their knowledge
of the gang was pathetic so they they
would show me these scraps of faxes it
intercepted and it were like well if
they just asked me I could have mapped
out the entire city then you know I
could I knew all this plus a lot more so
I'll come back to that at the end so
what do we learn did we learn anything
so I think we learned a lot it really
surprised me is sure now if I were
better a better economist I could have
predicted the results better than I did
so what do we learn from from the study
of the gang the first thing was just in
terms of the way the gang was structured
it was remarkably like a regular
corporation and particularly in
particularly like McDonald's is really
it's it's it's it's the org chart of
this gang and
it's identical they're both franchised
organizations in which there's some guys
at the top who make the big decisions
about brands and and you know expansion
of territory and but they don't really
do the day-to-day business they sell the
rights to a certain territory say six
week six blocks six four blocks and
those are franchise rights just like a
McDonald's gets a franchise a unique
franchise to sell in some certain area
and the person who runs the franchise is
the entrepreneur in the sense that that
person has to raise the money to either
buy the hamburger or buy the powder
crack of the powder cocaine and then
hire the workers and whatever is left
over at the end of the day that more or
less goes to the owner of the franchise
except they've got to pay up some share
of royalties and in the case of the gang
or something twenty percent of revenues
got paid up to the top to the top people
a second similarity between McDonald's
and the game were the wages so it turns
out that the guys at the top in this
gang were making four or five hundred
thousand dollars a year but there were
only about six or seven of them maybe
ten of them who were making that kind of
money the franchise owners in the sense
the local gang leaders they were making
about seventy-five to a hundred thousand
dollars here which it turns out is
almost exactly if you read franchisee
magazine is exactly how much you expect
to make if you run a local McDonald's
franchise and then at the bottom it
turns out that just like the burger
flippers for making minimum wage that's
exactly what the guys who were actually
selling the drugs on the street corner
we're making and that's the result which
I think is the most shocking one to
people and what's the one that surprised
me even knowing that the street corner
sellers were really only making minimum
wage so a fact that goes with that which
makes it hard to understand how it could
be true is that at the same time the
death rates were very very high so this
was a violent time there were gang wars
going out it was right at the peak of
crack and so the death rates were about
seven percent per year in this gang and
those are death rates that you would
have trouble finding in a war
so in our soldiers in Iraq nothing close
to that in terms of in terms of death
rates it's more like 1 to 2 percent a
year for our soldiers in Iraq
I think you have to go to like you know
fighter pilots in World War one or it's
just it's hard to find a group of people
who have that kind of death rate in the
book we talk about the official most
dangerous job in the US according to the
Bureau of Labor Statistics which is a
timber cutter but the death rates err on
the job or something like you know one
in two thousand per year so this is
orders of magnitude and really shows you
that in a very literal sense there was a
war going on on the streets in the inner
cities of America during the during you
know still but but especially during the
the peak of the crack epidemic so how do
you reconcile the fact that they're
making minimum wage and at the same time
they're having seven percent chance of
being killed who would take that job and
and that that's the clock they the
biggest the biggest puzzle and I think
the answer is twofold one is as we
talked about in the book the idea that
it was a tournament that that just like
the you know the high school football
quarterback who's taking steroids to do
better because he's got some pipe dream
of making it to the National Football
League and just like the homecoming
queen who you know drives out Hollywood
and waits tables for the next 15 years
hoping she'll get a good big break as an
as an actress
there is the drug trade is very much
like these other lucrative activities
where almost everyone toils in complete
obscurity makes almost no money and then
a few people that top make superstar
kinds of wages and it really was the
case that that was what the gang members
were after so how do we know that well
one thing is we can we can follow the
gang members over time and see at what
point did they drop out of the game and
it turns out that as soon as these gang
members got to be about 20 or 21 and
they saw other people being promoted up
the hierarchy but they themselves were
not being promoted they would drop out
of the game and this was a game where
you could drop out it was not hard to
drop out and and their own words are
also to that effect you know I'm not
going to be slinging on the corner
forever it's
move up or I move out I can't feed my
family doing this and so all of that
seems to to make sense and then so the
other question was can you really
believe they were making so little money
you know is it is it our imagination
were they lying and the data where the
data made up and I think the answer that
tells you that there are a lot of things
that tell you that they must not be
making very much money and one is this
idea about living with a mother so the
question why do they live with their
mothers because we're only making $5 an
hour they don't really have a choice
it's the only people who could afford
not to live at home with the people who
had moved up pretty high in the
hierarchy another thing was that I said
before that the the burgers slingers and
flippers and the drug dealers from
making about the same amount of money
well they were the same people it turned
out that over half of the kids who were
selling drugs were supplementing their
income working you know at at fast food
chains and whatnot which again is very
clear indication that if they were
making so much money in the gang they
wouldn't have wouldn't have been
bothering to to to do that and then the
third indication was as part of the deal
to get access with the gang and to to be
able to say survey them and you know get
their data they would occasionally ask
too dear for favors like to find good
jobs for those gang members who wanted
to to get out of the game and and he did
he accommodated them and he he had a
very good pipeline which led to good
jobs he knew the person who had the
concession to do the janitorial services
of the University of Chicago so it
turned out that in the minds of the drug
dealers being a janitor at the
University of Chicago was a great job
because it had benefits it was steady
work and and again it reinforces the
idea that that the the district was not
a very lucrative life at the bottom so
one thing and this is not in the book
but it's research I've done that follows
up with Sudhir that follows up on on
that work is so what happened to the
kids when they grew up so we're
following kids who were 16 17 18 well by
the end of the the period they were
about 25 26 27 and so because of
Sudhir's incredible contacts within this
community we were able to follow up
every kid who had lived in
one particular housing project house
every young male building every every
housing project building and and see
what they were doing roughly ten years
later and what was interesting and
surprising to me was that the the gang
members if you just look at the raw data
they were doing worse the former gamers
were doing worse than the than the other
kids but once you controlled for just
the the the slightest set of characters
and a few things and it turned out that
the single most important variable
actually was was the mother what's the
the child's mother a crack addict it
turned out that was the best predictor
of both being in the gang and having a
worse life outcome once your control for
a few things you found that the gang
members actually did just as well in
life it's an ongoing numbers conditional
I'm not dying so lots of the gang
members died but of the ones who
survived they actually their lives ten
years later looked amazingly similar so
in terms of the jobs they had and the
their marriages and whether or not they
were currently in jail those kind of
things really so it very much seemed
like the the most dire predictions which
is that getting in the gang was going to
ruin your life you could never escape
really weren't true that indeed the only
real difference you could see between
the gang members and non-being rumors
ten years later were that they both had
the same amount of wages but the gang
members were making more illegal income
they they for instance were more likely
to they had slightly worse jobs but they
sold more drugs at their jobs to to to
you know suburban white people who
needed to get access to the drugs that
they actually ended up compensating for
their lower wages that way so let me
just close and talking just a bit about
the the police so of course I was
talking about the trials that were going
on at the same time that we were getting
this data and publishing our work and so
you can imagine we worried a little bit
about what potential legal issues we
could be running into and in particular
we were worried that we would be
subpoenaed to get access to our data but
the thing is we were much more
frightened by the gang than we were by
the by the authorities
and so I said to Sudhir I said you know
if we get subpoenaed what do you know
what's gonna happen what do you think
will happen and he said well let's just
have to go to jail until the until the
grand jury is done and I said okay and I
could see how that was gonna be a very
good step for his career because I got
nothing you know what could be better
for a sociologist than to spend a few
months in jail and write about his
experiences being in jails if I thought
but I couldn't really see how it's gonna
be very beneficial to my crew so I said
to him I said okay that's fine
but it's a gang gonna protect us in jail
and he said well I know they're gonna
protect me you I'm not so sure about but
the good news was the authorities never
came after us they didn't seem to care
enough about our data to to give us any
film so let me stop there if that's
appropriate and then I'll take some
questions
so what while we're waiting for a
question I'll say I usually teach I
teach 9:00 a.m. I teach undergraduates
and I can't tell you how much more
enjoyable it is they have like a glowing
set of faces he was smiling at me
instead of mostly sleeping from the
other that's a great turnaround here's a
question past that there was this
precipitous drop in crime okay so let me
before I answer that question let me
explain to people who when the audience
don't know why you're asking that
question why you would be asking it so
along with John Donoghue who's a here's
a professor of law at Yale I put forth a
theory that suggested that the one of
the important reasons why we saw this
amazing unparalleled and unexpected
decline in crime roughly a 50% decline
in crime in 1990s was because of the
legalization of abortion with roe versus
wade roughly 20 years earlier and the
idea being that unwanted children are at
greater risk for crime and there's a lot
of evidence in the in the long-term
evidence supporting that and that
legalization of abortion reduced the
know around wanted children and
therefore you put those two together
there were 20 years later when those
kids grew up and reached their peak
primary years there were just you were
criminals there to do the crime okay so
now that's our hypothesis and it's and
it's well supported by the data so in
terms of just the raw time series roe
v-- wade was 1973 of course January 1973
and so the peak of crime the United
States depending on what you look at
looks like it's about 1991 and then
there's a steady decline for the for the
next ten years after but but our
hypothesis isn't really based on that
time series data I think you know there
are lots of the problem with using time
series data to support a hypothesis is
that there are lots of things that have
that pattern of you know they went up
for a while they went down for a while
and things changing so really our the
motivation behind our or the evidence
behind our story the motivation is
really the theory than the evidence
behind it
has to do more with looking at very
precise changes so for instance if you
compare the in the the mid-1970s despite
the legalization of abortion they were
radically different rates of abortion in
different states across the United
States so places like New York and
Washington DC had lots of legal
abortions and places like North Dakota
and Alabama had essentially zero legal
abortions so even though the law changed
there was no one providing the abortions
so if you look over the next 15 years
and you divide States into high abortion
states in the mid 70s and medium
abortion states and low abortion states
okay so over the next 15 years if you
compare the crime trends they're almost
identical you see no difference for the
next 15 years of what the crimes are
going up and down in the same sorts of
patterns and it's only starting 16 years
later that you start to see a divergence
between the crime and those sets of
states and it turns out it over the next
decade the crime in the high abortion
states fell about 30 percent relative to
the crime in the low abortion states and
all of that decline in crime is
concentrated solely among those born
after roe v wade that you don't see any
differences in the crime patterns for
those older than you know born before
1973 so that's more the kind of evidence
that we use in the book do you want to
follow that up yeah I was wondering if
you checked out any other variables for
instance alcoholism drug addiction
homosexuality various kinds of you know
social appa the--and so forth yeah so
we've looked at a lot of different so in
our in our analysis we do try to control
for alcohol consumption at the level of
the unit of analysis that we have and we
do control for things like prison and
police and and it is interesting so
there's another paper not work that I
did but but two researchers from
Michigan have done that finds that among
the cohort that's born right after roe
v-- wade actually there's a big drop in
drug use as teenagers and drug abuse is
teenagers so it kind of fits in that
same story there's also been evidence
that infanticide there was a killing of
children and both of babies and children
went
in the cohorts born immediately after
Roe vs. Wade there's sort of a more and
more evidence piling up on that on that
point sure professor for what it's worth
that bomber crews during the Second
World War especially in the first year
or two had about a 5% chance of dying on
each on each mission they went out on
and given that they started with 20
missions as their requirement before
they could go home this was a fairly
lethal environment and if you look at
the Indy 500 drivers they have about a 1
or 2 percent chance of getting killed
doing the Indy it's actually but these
are both high adrenaline activities
there's a lot or there's a lot of
patriotism associated to being a soldier
in combat
I'm just startled that people would take
on this level of lethality for the whole
level of reward is it you know are they
are they not viewing themselves as
having much of a of a forward future
therefore the risks aren't that bad or
is it you know are they bad at economics
or game theory yeah
well it's a good question we don't
really know the answer we can ask
question we look at the data we can ask
him questions and I think partly partly
they suffered from the same bad
decision-making that that maybe some of
you suffered from if you went out to
Silicon Valley in the middle of the
Internet boom thinking that you were
going to be the next wave of people
getting rich and so what happened was a
gang had before crack had never been
profitable it had been really more like
a rite of passage for for young men and
by the time they got to be 22 23
virtually everyone dropped out of the
game you couldn't make enough money in
the game to really make a career out of
it and so what happened with crack is
that suddenly by virtue of the nature of
crack it was it was a desirable drug it
was a relatively high price drug it was
very high volume and so crack really
became a way to make a living in the
gang and what what the cohort we were
looking at didn't properly take him to
cut was two things the first thing is
that
the cohort right above them right so
this is these are the people who ran the
gang in 1985 would never leave so it
turns out in Chicago the same guys who
ran the gangs in 1985 are all still
running the gangs and so these so is
very what's that they don't go into
politics well I'll tell you a story
about that one as well
and so these guys basically ran the gang
and they never gave up the reins and so
the guys who thought they're at the
bottom and projected up well people have
always dropped onto the gang at age 23
or 24 and then it'll be my turn to take
over they never got to take over and so
it's very much like I think this
parallel to that the guys who were
running the gang at that time were kind
of like the Bill Gates generation right
the people who are in the right place at
the right time they were the first young
kids who knew about computers and so
Bill Gates and his cohort made a ton of
money just by virtue of that and then
the well the analogy would make in the
gang is that this is cohort we're
looking at is more like pets.com it's
it's it's where you came in and you
would seen how a lot of other people
made money and you thought you would
make a lot of money too and it's a total
disaster you spend a lot of money on
Super Bowl ads and you don't sell hardly
any any dog food so let me tell you so
let me address the the question of
politics which is actually relevant so
supposedly there have been a deal worked
on this is all hearsay about how the
gang was going to be more or less
allowed to do what they wanted to do as
long as they stayed out of politics and
so right about the time when our data
ends our data end because the gang
decided to get involved in politics and
they ran their lawyer for Alderman and
he was doing pretty well and immediately
after that the police came down and
arrested every top member of the gang
including the gang leader that we were
collecting data from that that is the
abrupt end of our data because the the
gang leaders decided to get involved in
politics it's just
I knew a lot of guys who did the
internet stuff I knew a lot of people
who started the Silicon Valley business
I actually hire people for high-risk
activities right now and but you know
the guys I hire work on desperately
trying to reduce risk they probably
spend 90% of their effort trying to
understand control and look forward and
do these massive fault tree analysis so
that we can at least look ourselves in
the mirror the next morning and I'm just
I'm just startled that not only you know
you're not including in your analysis
the negative downside of doing five to
ten years in prison I mean getting
killed is fairly minor compared to seven
years of getting it in the well state
starting on the wrong part of the AHS
scenario it's uh well let me go back to
pass up that last part of the question
go back to the first part of the
question which had to do with with the
calculation of risk and I'll tell you a
big difference between people doing the
risky jobs you're talking about
and these gang members it has to do with
incentives and how you win this
tournament so indeed the guy who ran the
gang he hated the violence the violence
was the worst thing that could happen
for him because unlike when McDonald's
and Burger King get into some kind of a
price war right they they lower the
prices but but more and more people come
so they make up to a certain extent that
the smaller margins on quantity but in
the gang it is it's the opposite because
when you start shooting all of the all
of the customers are afraid to come in
the neighborhood so not only do your
prices follow during gang wars but your
your quantity souls fall as well so your
profits basically the game becomes a
negative in terms of profitability once
these gang wars are going on so you
might say well why are they doing this
why can't they figure it out no I can't
they they're close to your risk of
chicago free market to coast there and
all these things about efficient things
why can't they figure it out why don't
have to fight and it turns out it has to
do with incentives because the guys at
the bottom you're all these guys at the
bottom they all want to move up and how
do you convince somebody you're the one
to move up and it turns out that being a
guy who's seeing it's a little bit crazy
willing to kill willing to start fights
not afraid of anything
is the recipe for moving up and so it's
actually a real problem with
in the organization in terms of
incentives that the guys at the bottom
have the incentive to you know to be
seen as killers to be killers so they
can take over the top whereas the guys
at the top have every incentive for them
not to be killers both because it's you
know they're going to be the targets in
the long run potentially but also
because it hurts business and so I think
that's part of it you know it's like the
violence was actually part of the of the
goal of the guys at the bottom for for
making it to the top and look into the
cost of just doing five years in jail
I've talked to a lot of people about
your book who are really surprised if
this is economics and I'm an economics
major and this is kind of stuff that I
do I'm wondering if you could explain I
think this is the core of economics
whereas a lot of people would say this
is some strange arm
so there's wonder if you could give me
your definition of economics the science
okay well that makes sure if I ever do
another book for you I'm gonna bring you
in a view as so so why do I think this
is economics so many people classify
economics in terms of a subject matter
or a topic right so it's it's interest
rates its macroeconomic fluctuations
things like that and I think that's just
totally wrong I mean I think what
economics really should be thought of is
it as a set of tools it's coming it's
the set of tools for understanding human
behavior it's a set of ideas about how
to use data so one of the things about
economists if we don't have the luxury
of actually being able to do randomized
experiments right so in the hard science
physical sciences and even in psychology
you can do experiments and so you don't
have to think hard about what you would
do in the absence of randomized
experiments cuz you can do the
experiments but you know when I put in
my grant to the National Science
Foundation that says I want to lock up a
hundred thousand extra people and
release a hundred thousand you know
prisoners from a different state they
always reject those this grant so I've
got to find another way to try and
answer questions like that so we have
these set of data tools that are
designed to to go out in the real world
and use what we call natural experiments
or to come up with answers and the third
thing I think that special about
economics is that it it it's not
shackled by political correct
at all that that you can ask whatever
question you want and no matter how
outrageous the answer is other
economists at least will nod their head
say okay that makes sense and they don't
worry very much about what the broader
implications on so in that sense I think
that's where this really fits in is
economics is that it has the elements of
being about looking at all kinds of
human behavior and the last thing I
guess would say is incentive said really
I I am an economist in the sense that I
very much review the world through the
lens of its sentence but more more I
focus on kind of the dark side of
incentives most most economists think
that incentives are the tool that can
solve any problem and if you just give
them the right you know the right you
know power economists could make the
world a really good place to be whereas
in this book we really focus on well so
economists or politicians set up an
incentive scheme and then everybody else
goes out and says okay how can I beat it
you know what is it what is it what can
I do to figure out how to you know beat
the system and I think that's just as
important part of economics as oh thanks
I was wondering how dependent people in
your business in economics are on
ethnographers like mr. Venkatesh and the
studies that he does not nearly as
dependent as we should be I I can name
really on one hand I think the set of
economists I know who are actually
interested in ethnography and who who
read it voraciously I think that's a
problem in sunsets that that I find I
always learned more from reading
ethnography than I do from reading other
economics papers usually and and my hope
is that in the future there'll be more
more collaboration although I will say
and this might be partly apocryphal but
but so when when Sudhir was being looked
at for a job in the anthropology
department at the University of Chicago
the way it's told to me and I'm sure I'm
gonna get in a lot of trouble for saying
this on c-span but anyway so by the way
it's told to me is the following so he
did very well in the job talk that you
give and then there's a half an hour
session afterwards in which you discuss
your future research what you plan to do
so he made the mistake in that half an
hour afterwards and saying well there's
this really interesting economist we
shared the same building upstairs that
I'm working with to try to study this
use of gangs and gang finances to which
my impression was that his candidacy
immediately ended because anyway the
anthropologist on anybody who thinks
working with economists is the right way
to do things must be not really big
belong in our department so and he
didn't get the job and then so I was
relaying this story to my colleagues and
they said to me well but of course you
know if you didn't already have tenure
the fact that you're working with an
anthropologist would be just as damaging
to you and this department is this vice
versa so I think there's not enough
there should be a lot more and and kind
of I have a I think many people have a
view that that that academics should be
more interdisciplinary and I actually
think that that's not the right model
because the problem is it's too hard to
even be good at your own discipline much
less to be good at other people's
disciplines and so I kind of have a
model of being more what I
called a disciplinary where you take a
set of data tools and you don't pretend
I would never want to pretend that I
could be a decent ethnographer you know
I can barely make it as an economist and
so to think that I would suddenly be
qualified to do ethnography would be
silly but to kind of break down the
barriers and and work it's it's hard to
fight the right personality so it takes
it takes special people the kind of
people who self-select into say
anthropology for seeking out they're so
different to begin with that's hard to
find two people who can work together
and and make headway the way Sudhir and
I did but I really think it was it for
us a great model and and turned out far
better research than either of us could
have done on her thank you for the
question
all right um real quick question has
doing the research for this book or any
of your other studies given you I
suppose and the interesting thoughts
concerning human rationality well I'm
not I'm not big on human rationality I'm
not you know I'm from Chicago and we're
supposed to be you know big fans of
human rationality but I think I think
rationality is such a loaded word
because it comes with this idea of you
know being able to do really complicated
calculations in your head and having
full information and I think in general
for most of what we do number one we
don't have very full information and
number two it's not worth our time to
really necessarily try to get things
exactly right and so a lot of economists
are working on bounded rationality and
other models but more I think I think a
better way to think about it has to do
with incentive said basically people
people try to do what's good for
themselves okay and it's it's not that
they necessarily always get it right but
that more often than not if you if you
set up things to encourage their
behavior in one direction you can
influence your behavior in one direction
it's not you know it goes far beyond
humans it's true of of rats and pigeons
in the lab you can very much make them
respond and also putting in a plug for
for Dubner and my next adventure which
is we're going to be writing a monthly
column for the sunday New York Times and
so our first sunday New York Times
column is about monkeys and what
economists are now doing with monkeys
and what we're learning about monkeys
and money and how monkeys spend their
money when you
and so and there again you see monkeys
in the end like a whole lot like human
being say you know they're like rational
in some senses and irrational in other
cities that you know make us not look
too different thank you hello I was
wondering what about the actual business
aspect I mean keeping books retirement
plans and stuff like that within the
game so yeah so also also the second
part of the question is I mean the
banking and all of that stuff I'm
interested in that and then what aspects
of legitimate business mimic gang mimic
the game yeah that's that's a harder
question let me take the first one so in
terms of keeping books this thing was
somewhat unusual and indeed they were
keeping books precisely because the gang
leader had been this guy who had worked
in the mas department downtown and had a
college degree and had seen how to use
you know he knew how to use Lotus type
spreadsheets and was using these I
should say using these books to impress
the higher-ups and actually was very
successful in showing them how good he
was at doing business and moving up to
the top in terms of retirement benefits
given the death rates you might not be
surprised that they were not investing
heavily in these kind of things but what
the game did do was they paid off a lot
of money if a gang member got killed
they paid a fair amount of money so they
paid I forget the exact number two or
three years worth of the typical salary
was paid to the family of the victim and
they would pay for the funeral expenses
and and in their talk they talked about
how was cuz they're all family and they
had to do it but I think you know my
more more cynical view was that that
when people were getting killed there
was always bad for the gang and the
community support for the gang and so
they were in some sense trying to buy
off the loyalty on on the kinds of you
know I don't have a good answer to that
question about how corporations were
mimicking the gang I mean one thing I
think it's interesting is that when you
look at the gang that they were very
self
honestly mimicking the corporation's so
they were calling the the top level of
the gang was called the Board of
Directors and they were watching movies
like Wall Street and and taking their
clues from pop culture but what's
interesting is that so
at the same time that all the suburban
kids were like wearing Oakland Raiders
jackets and trying to be like the gang
members the inner-city kids were
watching Wall Street and trying to be
like the parents of the kids who were
wearing though hopefully Raiders jackets
I think there's I have no cultural
observer but I think there's something
interesting in the and the that cultural
phenomena I'd like to ask you an
economic question that's been bothering
me for years I'd like to ask you an
economic question that's been bothering
me for years I'm an open source advocate
programmer and it seems to me physically
that that's much the better way to go
and yet it's not being successful and I
don't understand why I wonder how you as
an economist would look at that problem
as it is it is a problem clear to you
yeah so if I understand open source the
idea is that you make the code available
to everyone so that's very easy for
other people to build all right now I
mean and I think the economic answer to
that and there's a much better economist
in the back Chris Snyder who could I'm
sure answer this question better me so
Chris if I give the wrong answer you got
to come up here and give the right
answer but the I mean I think the
obvious answer is that you know the way
the way you can charge high prices for
stuff is if you've got something that no
one else can replicate and so getting
the you know so so you know the idea of
a patent that excludes anyone from doing
another drug with the idea of making a
system that nobody else can hook into I
mean so we saw it with like beta versus
VHS is like there were two completely
different standards it was incredibly
inefficient but the one who was going to
win felt like they had more to gain by
winning on their own standard than by
being open source so I mean I think on
the other hand they are good economic
arguments for why open source is good
and get rid
a lot of this you know the difficulties
of you know why my blackberry doesn't
work when I'm in China which you know
there's no good reason for you know why
that shouldn't be the case if everybody
just cooperates long so I mean those are
I mean those are are there are competing
forces on on both sides and I think in
some cases you see people collaborating
on standards and in other cases you see
people doing their best to prevent that
and and I think it I think they're
they're doing forces that sometimes will
push you in the direction about gangs is
this the mic or is that selective yeah I
just I just want to say we're out of
time so I just want the people who are
in line now to be able to answer
questions in other words nobody joins
the line okay what about family you know
when we read when you see The Godfather
there are families at the top of gangs
that's not an economic kind of thing
that's the way power is transferred and
want many societies whether it's
capitalism communism or whatever how did
that influence the people who are coming
up or the culture of the game yeah
that's a good question so the gangs in
some sense are too young of
organizations to have this kind of
structure already built in it was really
it's really the night these gangs
emerged in the 1960s but but they had
never they weren't businesses and so
there was no there was no family passage
in the in the regular sort of way now it
is true that if you're you know father
had been a gang member to pick the gang
in the 60s it might have made it more
likely that you would be in that gang
growing up but but they really didn't
become money-making endeavors until the
mid 80s it's it's it's kind of like the
parallel to the again to the Internet
boom or like Microsoft so you know it's
probably unlikely that Bill Gates his
kids are gonna eventually run Microsoft
in the same way that it hasn't been the
case that the that the gang leaders kids
necessarily